hi Matt Welch here with my co-author
Nick Gillespie of the Declaration of
Independence with a T s we both work for
reason the magazine the institution of
free minds and free markets to ask a
libertarian day here our next question
comes from Tom k-6 286 who I believe is
a hot lesbian from Somalia the question
is what are libertarian solutions to
environmental problems global warming
pollution etc I think that the first
thing is to make sure that we're talking
about an actual problem and one that
demands immediate and massive action
with something like global warming I
believe that global warming is happening
I believe that man-made action has
contributed to it but the you know what
we're really talking about then mostly
is sea rise and the solution to that is
really to turn Bangladesh into South
Florida basically making everybody
wealthier so we're more resilient and
able to deal with weather conditions
that change more to the point we need to
think about things with pollution in
America you know there's no question
that the single biggest advance in air
quality over the past 40 years came from
two basic things first was the
imposition of a government mandate for
unleaded fuel in across the continent
that cleared the air so that in places
like Houston in LA which routinely
ranked as some of the worst air quality
in America it's vastly better than it
ever was back then with a lot more
people and a lot more activity there's a
role for the government coming in and
saying look there's a commons problem
here and we can't price things
effectively
so we're going to have to set up some
kind of one-size-fits-all regulation
there's a lot of ways to deal with that
typically gets done in the least
effective way but kind of privatizing
the problem privatizing any commons as a
way to solve the commons problem it's a
way of turning public toilets that are
disgusting into private facilities which
actually work pretty well and can be
even open to the public and you can see
this with things like endangered species
you know when when you can grow
elephants and when you can grow salmon
and
you can grow all sorts of things you get
more of them if you can recoup some of
that so a big part of it is privatizing
the Commons and another part of it is
also working towards those few areas
understanding and gaining a real
consensus that doesn't destroy an
economy in order to save it when we're
talking about real Commons problem yeah
and let's let's not make sure that poor
people continue being poor as the
solution to our sense of guilt for our
own pollution which I think animates a
little bit too much of a sort of
Environmental Policy going going forward